as Donald Trump made his way to the
stage in Mar-A-Lago he walked down an
aisle flanked on both sides by dozens of
his most loyal supporters with music
blaring people chanting his name it was
almost reminiscent of a boxer walking to
the ring and this was a classic
counter-punching performance by Donald
Trump it was an exhibition in what about
ISM what about the secret documents
found in Joe Biden's residence he said
what about Joe Biden's son Hunter Biden
he also went on on the attack against
the judge who's presiding over this case
he said he was a trump-hating judge with
a trump hating wife and family really
was an exhibition in deflection this and
it played well to the audience
um inside they were cheering on his
every word his every statement and
polling suggests that that sentiment is
mirrored by Republican voters across
this country Trump's advantage over
Republican Rivals for the candidate for
the candidacy for the 2024 election for
the Republican Party The Gap is only
widening in Trump's Advantage he's also
raised seven million dollars at least in
campaign donations since these charges
became public last week so even though
he's in this incredible legal mess he is
eking out a political Advantage here